j'habite à la bretagne
j'ai deux enfants dont une fille que tu
as beau temps bon en situation de
handicap martin c'était très difficile
jeudi à la réunion de vivre avec un
enfant
donc là j'ai cherché un peu autour de
moi il n'y avait pas beaucoup
d'associations mais on était quand même
mais des groupes de parole avec des
familles au pouvoir mais les centres et
des dons il ya une notice réunion donc
on s'est investi dans l'autisme à une
autre association c'est la hache est
habitué
qui existe depuis 2005 en vacances et là
je me suis investi beaucoup à cette fois
avec les petits mots 2000
cette eau est fao le
il y crée le seuil de 10 sociale est là
et bien pareil je m'investis la dent les
parents me demandent de les représenter
dans ce conseil de vie sociale
elle même s'est beaucoup oublié pour les
autres toujours à donner à aider lé au
téléphone de du matin au soir et du soir
au matin on va dire c'est du temps
donner aux autres chiens d'eau totale de
sa personne